[Music]
who did this certainly wasn't me
no no somebody not me must have moved it
between the time I was the last person
alone with the body in the room and then
stepped out for a few minutes to take
care of some personal business now you
don't need to know about could have been
anybody except me what the hell happened
here the body's been moved on its own no
of course not unless it did in which
case we've got way bigger problems than
a simple murder on its own we haven't
quite ruled that out just yet but let's
not forget we've got a murderer quite a
storm out there a chaps
what are you doing huddled in here in
fear we have a zombie problem ah hold on
closest the most dangerous game well
someone needs to put the old lad down
again I'm well up for the privilege what
do you mean by again and what do you
mean by privilege I'm just saying I've
got plenty of experience on the matter
so do I yeah that just raises more
questions well I'm off to the grounds to
see if I can catch a whiff of the old
bag of bones all right
I don't trust him then again I don't
trust anyone
all right lock this place down secure
the front gate I don't want anyone in or
out of this place until we get to the
bottom of this lot someone keep people
from getting out sir
locks whoa [ __ ] we'll look you're a
real smart son of a [ __ ] handsome too
beautiful even but we don't have time
for this I think we forgot the most
important question of all during our a
rousing game of whodunit why why
God walk with me why did you bite us all
here why tonight he said we were
celebrating something but he never
specified what it's almost as if this
whole shindig of a hootenanny was just a
ruse
Marc was my friend had been for years
with anyone quiet I knew something was
wrong I just never figured out what now
I guess I never will look I'm gonna
level with you
you're my new partner I've been working
with them for years now I've been doing
this for a long time and I know
something is wrong there is a murderer
you're amongst us we need to find it you
look like a trustworthy somebody I know
we just met but I am an excellent judge
of character
excellent like a fox I smiled and fed
him a line of [ __ ] the truth was I
couldn't trust them any more than the
other skies around here but like my late
partner once said right before he died
best to keep your enemies close wait
quick you don't look like you have a
reason to kill him and if you do best to
keep your enemies close a wink wink so
the real question we should be asking is
who stood to gain the most from Marc's
death
now in my thorough analysis of the
corpses anal cavity I discovered that in
addition to being stabbed 37 times he
was also poised beat strangled drown and
shot in that order now he asked me
that's a lot of trouble to go through
the knock off one guy and the church
[ __ ] is no accident no no my friend
there's gonna be no simple candlestick
in the library solution to this whole
puzzle so we're gonna have to do the
detective Lee thing
and go through the victims most private
in personal possessions well after you
[Music]
oh it was rough but I don't think he was
killed here take a look around see if
you find anything but be careful I've
lost three partners before 2-bedroom
booby traps make sure you don't tamper
with any evidence
[Music]
anything you find a clue
you're quite on the case aren't you say
detective may I borrow your friend here
yeah sure
don't worry partner I'll handle it from
here take a walk with me I thought that
it was about time that we got to know
each other
someplace far far away from the prying
eyes of anyone else now correct me if
I'm wrong but you're the mayor know each
other right
he's a good man that one we've been fast
friends for as long as I can remember
now there came a time when I could say
the same thing about mark but well
that's not to speak ill of a daddy-o the
pool has an age today
have you seen the [ __ ] I thought I heard
him I need to speak with him I may have
been a little short at a last encounter
well if you do see him let me know
Oh life needs a bit of madness a chat
now what were we talking about
oh yes the grisly business inside well
I'm sure I'm not the first to say that
our hosts had a great deal of enemies as
of late my prying eye might suspect that
the people who worked for him might have
reason to stab him in the back
God knows he's a tough son of a [ __ ] to
work for Oh
the old golf course I offered my plums
colonel damn I thought I heard him no
matter would you accompany me there's
something of that I would but I must
like to discuss with you
now I know you've been assisting our
intrepid detective with his
investigation but I have to bring some
concerns of mine to the forefront
if we look at this situation logically
we can only assume that the killer who
struck down our dear friend mark was
with us last night and while I would
stake my life on the innocence of the
colonel or yourself can we really say
the same of our beloved detective or
worse yet mayhaps are counting skills on
as good as we assume them to be and
mayhaps in the shadows of this Manor
unseen to any of us lay hidden murder
I don't know what you're playing at but
you better lower your weapon you
murderer you're the one that assaulted
me for all I know you could beat the man
last chance
drop your weapon everyone please I know
we're all on edge but can't we resolve
this amicably on edge this cycle tried
to choke me that's a bold-faced lie I
was maybe doing some like target
practice inside yes I couldn't go on the
grounds now with that bloody chef in my
way could I do this sure to remember
that pilot he said you're not my boss
anymore
Carl enough of this horseshit you knew I
was onto you and you were trying to
whack me off before I could finger you
that's the murderer in my own home
[Music]